around the globe glaciers and the ice of
the polar caps are melting
sea levels are rising
incidences of extreme weather like
droughts torrential downpours and
flooding are increasing
experts say this is the result of
climate change caused by global warming
the pace of global warming has slowed
somewhat over the last 15 years
it's plateaued
but we shouldn't forget there have been
plateaus before
climate change isn't always just a
smooth rise
there are also natural fluctuations
but the overall trend remains unchanged
around the world temperatures continue
to rise
oceanographers regularly check the
temperature of the seas their salinity
levels and changes in sea levels
comprehensive measurements like these
have only been taken for the past three
decades
the lack of data from the past makes it
difficult to predict future trends
scientists assume that as the water of
the oceans grows warmer and expands sea
levels around the world will rise
but they do know that sea levels won't
increase by the same amount everywhere
take greenland for example where climate
change is causing the island's vast ice
sheet to melt with surprising
consequences for local sea levels
a model shows what happens when
greenland's ice melts
represented here by the blue weight
is in greenland we see that greenland
rises because the ice mass is gone
and we also see that the ocean
redistributes itself while maintaining
the same volume
water levels at the coastal areas around
greenland actually go down
but the waters around other coastlines
rise higher than ever
here in the tropical regions the
increase is actually greater than the
increase caused by regular climate
change alone by the warming of the
oceans
professor model can't yet demonstrate
processes like this
it can't factor in influences unrelated
to climate change either
land rising or sinking can be due to
things like groundwater being pumped out
or the extraction of natural gas and so
on these local events can also lead to
changes in sea levels
to understand how much i'll give you one
figure
the removal of groundwater has caused
tokyo to sink some six metres
hamburg's waterfront development project
huffin city was built to withstand flood
waters the buildings are constructed on
plinths on top of compacted fill
during a storm search the promenade
would be flooded right away but the
apartments and businesses on their
raised bases would be protected
even if as researchers predict flood
waters reach unprecedented heights and
future still more research is needed
he
there are aspects which aren't fully
understood yet
the entire cryosphere ice sheet dynamics
the predictions and prognosis of the
behavior of the polar ice caps for
example
these models are still in their infancy
and for the moment create uncertainty
when it comes to predicting rising sea
levels
but the builders of hamburg's harford
city have certainly taken the climate
researchers core message to heart and
made it the foundation of this
waterfront project